it's appalling
Capcom exclusive right now I'm gonna do
Juicy J yeah yellow boss hey first of
all I was crazy
mighty being about just like world
domination two three six months yo like
yeah man Thank You Man yeah the joint
with yellow will have me really wanted
to go I noticed to your live show like
you I'm like I couldn't start each song
like a champ you know what I'm saying
that is because everybody turns up man
yeah hey um you had a legendary Roman
three 6 mafia yep you guys want awards
you guys did your thing what has been
better the Roma 3 6 or this Renaissance
of Juicy J as a solo artist like you
almost are bigger than ever now by
yourself doing every damn thing
obviously both of them them you know Sam
cuz being on a group you know you get
the group experience and then you get
the solo thing it took solo experience I
mean I'm saying I love my career I love
everything I've done and every every
decision I've decided to make great is
it like weird like jumping on a record
with Katy Perry like it's like you're
like a household name now I mean it's a
blessing because I never thought that
was gonna happen
and when it happened that was like I
don't he believes it happen you know
saying and when she would lose his song
I was like wow you know cuz the response
is so great and you know shuts up to
Katy Perry dr. Luke you know I'm saying
just making things happen to me what
it's like unbelievable to be right now
you know sad for me because it's really
because I remember I remember the
mixtapes you were dropping yeah and and
they would you know get a little bit of
buzz in each one each one the stage for
me [__] you started a brand that [__]
and it's right now you doing
I mean records with everybody who's
somebody who you who's popping right now
or maybe a remix that you you are
feeling that you know you might want to
hop on that might kind of catch people
off-guard I wish I mean be real I wish I
could do something with a deal man
cuz I think people would be like what
the [__] Thank You CJ Emmerdale
that Lord's doing their royal joint yes
something-something just like straight
to the left and I'm saying but as far as
like on a rap tip I would love to do
something without with jay-z man and nas
you know nas like my favorite rapper of
all times you know Jay Electronica I
like him and you know say he's dope a
lot of hip-hop is way here that'd be
like you Juicy J listen electronica yeah
I listen to everything like a lot of
people understand is like high music is
me man you know this is what I breathe
eat every day you know I love music I
love a lot of different kind of artists
if nas is your favorite MC of all time
what's your favorite album of all time
what's the one the one he had to eat the
wrong that's pneumatic yes they're my
omegas classic classic straight classic
do you feel like I feel like person that
for my gira underrated MC yourself but I
feel like you don't get enough do as far
as like being a great emcee like I feel
like you you'd be spitting sometimes act
like sometime you you you don't you're
not having that regard with a lot of
people do you feel like you're a little
underrated in a category I mean not
really man cuz I could see myself
produce I never really said myself a
rapper right you know saying I started
as a you know DJ Dan a producer and you
know I liked it I'm a type of God man I
was like I was always like a
behind-the-scenes kind of guy you know
Sam but I love music so much that you
know he just brought me to the funds
being underrated even as a producer yeah
I mean yeah it's real trying you know
produce numerous of Records so meeting
these meetings making the records made
in number three it's cutting the war you
mean like you know I've done a lot and a
lot of people don't know that and if you
people that do know that some people
shall know some people just don't
understand but you know but it's all
good man cuz I just like being in you
know being in a in the midst of the
music it's not about if somebody gives
me props I don't really care about all
that
right right right yeah of course you
gotta you think imma whiz right now I
saw that Paul and crunchy and
everybody's putting out like yep not
necessarily a three 6 mafia I wants to
call the Mafia say yep is it what is the
deal with that like is there a reason
we're not part of it is it
I mean why what's going on with that I
mean right now I've been doing my thing
you know
just doing this let Juicy J run but like
I salute you all and I love those guys
man apparently what man those men like
we made history together universe and
and and and moving forward anything they
would want me to do I would definitely
to do it album whatever you don't matter
because I'm out still I'm a part of that
group and I'm still a part of that that
movement you know sound at the end of
the day so I would definitely love to do
something with those guys man can you
see yourself ever doing that three six
might be on yeah yeah always yeah we
made history man like I said we made
history by the your music right today it
sounded like that oh [__] you know sir
so of course man hey being a line Wiz
and T gob like I know you're a og in the
game you got around you know is you know
eight school you feel me well what's
some that you've learnt from like win
Cisco for their own way you know who one
of the original rappers who really use
the internet says benefit what's
something you've learned from Wiz even
though you said that's a lot of things I
learned from with like button to the
internet just the 30 days I saw we're
doing a day to day is like y'all make up
some day two days you know you gotta
keep it moving like that so I started
doing the day to days as well you know
I'm sad which is a super talented man he
works hard just like me you know I'm
saying he's always in the studio making
its making just making music you know so
you got so much music probably been
recorded maybe 200 songs right he bought
the release when you hand them all of my
[__] hits bang it you know I'm saying
so I get a lot I get a lot of uh you
know like motivation from where's man
you know I'm saying cuz I see him in the
studio working you know just like me
when I was like you know his age man you
know so that just keeps me motivated as
well dr. Sam and I heard you talking
earlier that uh
Jimmy Kimmel did the thing where like
your mom was supposed to yeah we're
supposed to read some of the lyrics and
one of your songs
yeah you said your mom didn't cuss nice
my mom does not cuss at all no she does
not
okay so how often do you hear from your
mama which is like here's a join of
yours it might be a little over the edge
you ever hear from your mama no she
loves my music man she respects what I
do because they know it's just music you
know right like I matter
cutting the person hand out for going to
jail for some stupid [__] so she
respects my music and I'm saying I love
her a lot because she supports me
hundred percent but I didn't
Amazon now stay trippy yes some stores
right now go pick that up I'm on at Best
Buy you know I'm saying about AB why I
told you looks out my best spot it's
crazy
anything on the horizon Taylor getting
album selling album coming soon Wiz
Khalifa album coming soon
ty dolla sign just got to make statement
super dope burning just dropping mixtape
Chevy Woods is coming soon I mean we got
a lot of stuff going on right now man we
just work it man you know sad man go get
our gets crazy Juicy J bootleg heavy
already know